for years and years Disney has brought
magic happiness and adventure to the
lives of kids adults and Disney fans
everywhere as amazing as Disney as
though it isn't perfect although its
movies and characters help shape
generations of Disney fans everywhere
this video is for those of you brave
enough to question everything you grew
up watching watch until the end to find
out which Disney movies major plot hole
managed to slip by millions of people
Princess and the Frog so let's start off
this video with a look into the
adventures of our personal favorite
princess who is an amazing role model
excellent cook and wonderful singer this
princess is Tiana from the Disney
classic Princess and the Frog just 1
unless you beg for more now if you're
wondering what could possibly be wrong
with sweet Tiana's fairy tale the answer
is nothing at all at least not when it
comes to Tiana herself the plot hole
we're going to talk about actually
involves her best friend Charlotte just
in case you guys don't remember
Charlotte was Tiana's bubbly and loyal
best friends who was introduced as an
all-around princess near the end of the
movie Mama Odie tells Naveen and tiana
that the only way to reverse the curse
and return to their human form is for
Prince Naveen to kiss a princess since
Charlotte's father was crowned the king
of mardi gras she did technically
qualify as a princess for 24 hours that
is we know that the clock strikes
midnight before Charlotte ever got to
kiss Prince Naveen so why didn't she
turn into a frog just like Tiana did
while we don't know the answer to that
question we are going to give our girl
Charlotte the benefit of the doubt and
assume that her father may have been
crowned to the king of mardi gras for
longer than just the day Toy Story next
up is the one and only Toy Story if you
guys have watched our Toy Story 4 video
then you know that this Disney classic
is set to air in June 2019 with the
highly anticipated movie right around
the corner we thought it would only be
right to include the franchise in our
list of Disney plot holes to the
question we have for the Toy Story
creators is why did Buzz Lightyear
freeze in front of Andy every time that
he walked into the room well the obvious
answer that first comes to mind is that
he doesn't want any humans to know that
toys are alive because the result would
probably be
genera except doesn't buzz totally
reject the idea that he is a toy
throughout pretty much of the entire
movie so why then would a space
commander on an intergalactic mission
freeze whenever Andy came into the room
we don't really have the answers for you
guys but let's hope that this plot hole
is clarified in the upcoming movie
Cinderella if you've made it this far
it's safe to say that you are one brave
Disney fan let us know by leaving a
green heart in the comment section now
let's take a little throwback journey to
Cinderella's magical fairy tale
Cinderella story was one for the ages
with a gorgeous soundtrack and
captivating storyline Cinderella was one
of the few princesses to come in contact
with a fairy that was in fact her very
own fairy godmother fairy godmother was
ready to wave her wand and make all of
Cinderella's dreams come true except for
one minor detail that we're hoping was
all a part of the fairy godmothers
master plan she tells Cinderella that at
the stroke of midnight all of the magic
spells keeping Cinderella's enchanted
items in their forms would be broken
this would mean that her carriage would
turn back into a pumpkin her horses back
into mice and her gown and slippers back
into rags and shoes now you might all
see where we're going with this if
everything was meant to turn back into
its original form then why does
Cinderella's glass slipper remain as it
was what do you guys think tangled now
we have Rapunzel from the fan favorite
tangled movie with her gorgeous long
blonde hair and fun-loving personality
it is no wonder that Rapunzel was quick
to become one of Disney's most beloved
princesses her adventures with Flynn
or should we call him Eugene and the
rest of the gang how does absolutely
charmed by the spirited princess fairy
tale but this video isn't exactly meant
to point out what we love about these
Disney movies so let's get right down to
business so if you've seen our princess
Sofia video then you know that
Rapunzel's healing powers come from a
magical golden flower the flower has
healing properties that were given to
Rapunzel's mother after she fell ill
during her pregnancy this is the
original movies idea behind why
Rapunzel's hair is magical in the scene
where Flynn cuts her hair you may have
noticed it
Brown now this might have made sense if
Rapunzel's healing powers were just in
her hair except we know that that isn't
true we see proof of that when
Rapunzel's Tears say Flynn telling us
that the actual healing power is inside
of her following that logic wouldnt the
leftover hair still connected to her
body stay blonde
and why did Mother Gothel turn to dust
if Rapunzel's Magic's were still ablaze
this Disney plot hole has puzzled us
from the get-go but we love tangled so
much we're willing to give it the
benefit of the doubt the Little Mermaid
last but definitely not least is a plot
hole that we just wish we could unlearn
but for those of you brave enough to
have made it this far we hope you're
ready this fairy tale was brought to us
a pretty long time ago but has remains
one of Disney's top tier movies until
this very day this underwater fairy tale
is none other than the Little Mermaid we
love Ariel her charming prince gorgeous
sisters and loyal friends so we
definitely never wanted to believe that
there could be something wrong with this
iconic tale in the first Little Mermaid
movie Ariel signs a contract with Ursula
in order to turn herself into a human
and pursue Prince Erik now the only
issue is that she trades in her voice
and can't exactly defend herself when he
falls under Ursula's in disguise spell
so why did an Ariel just write Erik a
letter explaining everything who we see
that she can read and write as she signs
her name on the contract so what exactly
where the Disney creator is thinking
well we don't have the answers for you
guys we can definitely tell you that our
childhood favorites will never be the
same still that's never stopped us from
watching them over and over again and
let's face it Disney movies are where
it's at before you go make sure to let
us know which Disney plot hole you found
to be the most shocking and let us know
if you've ever spotted some Disney plot
holes of your own and that's a wrap give
this video a big thumbs up if you
enjoyed it thanks for watching the
things see you next time
[Music]